it's about time you got your own movie
Natasha Romanov Black Widow has been
such an important part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe you have such an
interesting and mysterious backstory you
were trained as a Russian spy before
becoming a member of shield and now you
risk your life every day for the sake of
others that's truly heroic Black Widow
is finally coming out in 2020 we are so
excited to see a movie all about you the
new decade is starting off with some
amazing new movies there are a bunch of
films you don't want to miss keep
watching to find out the top ten movies
in 2020 you should care about onward we
don't know about you but we get super
pumped every time Disney and Pixar team
up these awesome production companies
are releasing two movies in 2020 the
first one is called onward and it's all
about the world of trolls and other
creatures set in a modern-day setting
and it looks epic ian is a young troll
who turned 16 he doesn't remember his
father who passed away when he was young
Ian's older brother barley only
remembers him a little Ian's mom gives
him a gift of their father who was
supposedly an accountant left behind
it's a magical staff with a spell to
bring back their dad for one day but the
spell goes haywire they only managed to
bring half of their dad back the bottom
half that is we've only got 24 hours to
bring back the rest of that so they go
on an adventure to bring him back for
good
there are fairy biker gangs magic and
feral unicorns these brothers are on a
quest to discover if magic still exists
in the world Tom Holland voices Ian and
Chris Pratt is barley this movie looks
hilarious and a really sweet that's
exactly what we'd expect from Pixar
onward drops on March 6 2020 Wonder
Woman 1984 DC's leading lady is back
with a brand new movie Wonder Woman 1984
is going to be one action-packed wild
ride the teaser trailer looks awesome
but the actual plot is still a little
unclear
here's what we do know it takes place
about 40 years after the first Wonder
Woman movie gal gadot is back as Deanna
there appears to be two major villains
one is a guy named Max Lord who is
played by Pedro Pascal the other is a
woman played by Kristen Wiig we don't
usually see this funny actors outside of
comedy
but we're sure she's gonna bring some of
her signature humor she appears to be
friend Diana but she is also a villain
named cheetah Steve Trevor comes back -
we are excited that Chris Pine is back
as Diana's love interest and a partner
but we have so many questions we thought
he sacrificed himself in the first movie
and he's human unlike Diana
why doesn't he appear to have aged at
all in the last four decades we can't
wait to find out all about it in the new
movie
Wonder Woman 1984 comes out in June that
justice trashcan was just a trash can
yeah yeah birds of prey 2020 is the year
for comic book girl power Harley Quinn
played by Margot Robbie was a fan
favorite in the 2016 movie Suicide Squad
this time she gets her own movie birds
of prey and the fantabulous emancipation
of one Harley Quinn gives us a new
insight into the villain in the movie
she has split up with the Joker she
seems to be feeling a little lost
without him but she's ready to find
herself she teams up with three other
bad chicks to save a young girl from an
evil crime lord we just love an antihero
movie and it's about time we get one
with an awesome cast of women so who is
on Harley's new squad Mary Elizabeth
Winstead plays Huntress
jurnee smollett bells plays Black Canary
and a Rosie Perez stars as Brenna
Montoya the villain is played by you and
McGregor the movie has Harley's
endearing innocence humor as well as
some epic fight scenes you can see birds
of prey on February 7th Dolittle when
you hear dr. Dolittle you probably think
of the Eddie Murphy movies from the late
90s and early 2000s but the history of
the man who could talk to animals goes
way back there were a series of books
written in the 1920s in the 1960s an
epic musical adventure starring Rex
Harrison came out the new Dolittle is a
homage to that first Doctor Dolittle
movie and it looks like a fun animal
adventure you can Robert Downey jr.
stars as the doctor who discovers he can
talk to animals characters from the
original movie including titi the eighth
and Polynesia the bird are played by
huge stars
Balak voices TT and the great Emma
Thompson is the wise bird this movie is
full of swashbuckling seafaring
adventures and we are pumped we can't
think of a better person to play the
doctor than Robert Downey jr. Doolittle
releases in January and it's not far
away get ready to go on a journey with
the man who can talk to animals sonic
the hedgehog there are a few video game
characters more beloved than Sonic the
Hedgehog and in 2020 the world's fastest
hedgehog is getting his own live-action
movie but this movie hasn't come without
controversy
Sonic the Hedgehog was supposed to come
out sooner but fans were outraged by his
animation style the creators didn't want
a flop
so they reanimated Sonic to look more
like the classic character in the movie
Sonic who is voiced by Jim Carrey comes
to earth he is trying to escape from
people who want his powers but he is
discovered here on earth too he
befriends a man named Tom who is played
by James Marsden together these two have
to run from the people who would destroy
Sonic
it looks hilarious fun and even
heartwarming it's an action adventure
with a story about friendship this movie
is great for all the Millennials who
grew up playing the video game but it's
also going to be great for a new
generation of kids sonic the hedgehog
drops on Valentine's Day 2020 are you as
excited as we are about all the new
movies in 2020 click that big red button
to subscribe to the things for lots of
coverage about Hollywood's hottest hits
if you're watching on mobile make sure
your notifications for YouTube are
enabled then you'll never miss another
awesome video Scoob
Scooby dooby doo where are you it looks
like you're headed back to the big
screen the world's smartest talking dog
and his gang of mystery solving teens
have been in many TV shows and movies
and they never get old Scoob is the
latest movie about the Great Dane and
his friends part of the movie is their
origin story we see how Shaggy and
Scooby meet shaggy save Scooby from
animal control and it's the sweetest
thing ever
his names are you Scooby last name do we
also see how these two BFFs meet Velma
Fred and Daphne but then we jump forward
in time to a new mystery adventure that
appears to involve
aliens it looks like something from the
gangs past has come back to haunt these
meddling kids
Scoob has an all-star cast of voice
actors Zac Efron plays Fred and Amanda
Seyfried is Daphne Gina Rodriguez is the
super-smart Felmy shaggy is voiced by
comedian Will Forte the movie is
expected to release in May
what other beloved character is being
brought to life in the new movie keep
watching to find out zombies - ok this
movie might not be heading to the big
screen but it's still a highly
anticipated movie that we know is going
to be awesome
zombies - is the sequel to the fun
Disney Channel original movie zombies
the first movie was super popular
it had lovable characters and amazing
musical numbers Disney Channel is still
being pretty tight-lipped about the new
movie we do know a few things though
Milo Mannheim and Megan Donnelly are
coming back as Zedd and Addison most of
the original cast is returning to
zombies have fully integrated into the
town but then werewolves arrive it's
going to cause a big division in the
residents of Seabrook and it's even
going to cause a rift between Addison
and Zedd we are so excited to see this
new movie we've only gotten a sneak peek
and a couple of teaser so far we bet a
full-length trailer will drop soon the
expected release date is February 14th
sole we love it when Pixar gives us
movies that make us really think they
did it in inside out a few years ago now
they're back with a new movie called
soul the first trailer dropped recently
the movie looks intriguing and really
deep the voiceover of the whole trailer
talks about finding your passion it asks
what you want to be remembered for when
you're gone Jamie Foxx voices a musician
according to the description he has lost
his passion for music but in the trailer
he seems excited about an upcoming gig
then he falls in a manhole he is
transported to a realm where he is just
a soul he's stuck with a new younger
soul who was voiced by Tina Fey she is
still figuring out who she is together
they have to find their way back to the
human world we just know that this
Disney and Pixar project is going to hit
us right in the fields
Jacque alive you can see Seoul in
theaters on June 19 20 20 lakh widow our
final girl powers superhero flick comes
from the Marvel Cinematic Universe it's
about time we get to look at black
widows story Black Widow is all about
Natasha Romanoff who is played by
Scarlett Johansson when the first
trailer dropped everyone thought Black
Widow would just be her origin story we
know that she became friends with
Hawkeye and that's how she defected from
Russia but now it appears that the movie
is about a lot more than that it takes
place between civil war and infinity war
natasha has to confront her past and
reconnect with the people from Russia
she meets up with her sister and other
spies who appear to be family are these
her actual blood relatives or just
people from her spy training will get
flashbacks to her Russian spy days we'll
also find out what she was up to before
Thanos went and messed everything up we
cannot wait to find out more about the
coolest chick in the Avengers Black
Widows expected release is May 1st
Mulan Disney is still writing the
live-action remake wave in 2020 they are
bringing Mulan to life and it looks epic
while Aladdin and Beauty and the Beast
stayed pretty close to the original
versions Mulan is something totally new
it's still the story of a girl who takes
her father's place in the army and ends
up saving China but this movie isn't a
light-hearted comedy like the animated
film it's an epic drama there are new
characters the Huns have a witch and
Mulan has a sister moo shu and li Shang
are not part of the cast's but we are so
pumped to see this new take on the
classic story of Mulan it will probably
be a lot closer to the original Chinese
legend Mulan will still save China and
bring honor to her family and it looks
like she doesn't need a love story to do
it she is played by ufa leo
the Emperor is played by the great Jet
Li we can't wait Mulan comes to theaters
in March and that's a wrap which 2020
movie are you most excited about let us
know in the comments
thanks for watching be sure to give us a
big thumbs up see you next time
you